las acciones de una compañía representan
cuánto posee una persona de esta los
propietarios de la compañía sierra
silvestre son marina benito e isabel
marina posee cuatro mil cincuenta
acciones
benito 2.510 acciones e isabel posee
cuatro mil 200 acciones supongamos que
la compañía obtuvo ganancias este año
por un millón quinientos mil pesos un
millón quinientos mil pesos
si cada accionista obtiene una utilidad
proporcional de estas ganancias respecto
a las acciones que posee cuánto dinero
en pesos recibirá isabel
bien veamos que isabel tiene 4.200
acciones
aquí ponemos 4200 acciones
los únicos propietarios de esta compañía
son marina benito e isabel entonces el
total de las acciones de esta compañía
pues son las que posee cada uno de ellos
la suma de las acciones de cada uno
las acciones de marina que son cuatro
mil cincuenta vamos a escribirle aquí
cuatro mil cincuenta más las 2500 diez
que tiene benito
más
las que ya conocíamos las 4.200 que
posee isabel
entonces la fracción que le corresponde
de las utilidades a isabel pues será
esta que está aquí bien utilicemos una
calculadora para hacer estos cálculos
les voy a extraer la calculadora
tenemos que hacer esta operación 4.200
lo vamos a dividir
entre la suma
de 4.050
mas 2.510 más 4.200
nuestros paréntesis
y esto nos da a 0.39 y en fin con muchos
decimales así que vamos a aproximarlo a
0.39 o sea el 39% es el que le
corresponde a isabel a ver vamos a
escribirlo
entonces vamos a decir que esto es
aproximadamente a 0.39 el 39% es lo que
tiene isabel y ahora vamos a escribirlo
isabel
obtiene
aproximadamente este símbolo se utiliza
para decir aproximado
0.39 de las utilidades y para calcularlo
entonces tendríamos que multiplicar el
0.39 por el millón y medio
un millón quinientos mil pesos es
obtuvieron de las ganancias y esto ha
que será igual
bueno pues voy a regresar otra vez a mi
calculadora y entonces aquí ya tengo el
número exacto que había hecho yo de mi
operación y entonces ahora lo voy a
multiplicar
por 1.500.000 1-2-3 verificó que el
número de ceros sea el correcto y
obtengo 585 mil quinientos dos puntos y
otra vez una expresión decimal larga que
nos están diciendo que tenemos que
redondear la respuesta al centavo más
cercano o sea que lo vamos a redondear a
punto 86 a ver voy a poner esto en un
lugar donde pueda verlo para copiarlo el
resultado es de 585.000
501 pesos con 86 centavos nada mal le
fue isabel creo que con estos dividendos
que obtuvo por sus acciones podrá vivir
muy cómodamente los próximos años